[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMES MALONE: Hello everybody.
I'm James Malone.
I'm a product manager
on Google Cloud.
And one of the products that
I am product manager for
is Google Cloud Dataproc.
And today I want to talk to
you about using the open source
set of tools that are in the
Apache and Spark ecosystem
at data processing on
Google Cloud Platform.
So we're going to talk
about a few things today.
First we're going to talk
about the tools themselves.
They're great, they
bring a lot of benefits,
but they also bring a lot of
complexities and headaches.
And we're going
to talk about how
we want to solve that
using hardware and software
innovations that are a part
of Google Cloud Platform.
I'm going to put my money where
my mouth is and do a live demo.
And we're going to create a
pretty big Spark and Hadoop
cluster to show you what
we can do at scale, some
of the speeds, and some
of the tools that we have
and that we bring to the
Spark and Hadoop ecosystem.
And then from there
I want to share
a bunch of really
new exciting things
that we just launched in
preparation for Google Next.
So the first thing that
I want to talk about
is the complexity of the
Spark and Hadoop ecosystem.
These tools are
really, really great,
but they often bring a lot of
painful headaches with them.
So typically when you set up
a Spark and Hadoop cluster,
it's not a sort of
simple or linear process.
If you are familiar with
setting up a Spark and Hadoop
cluster on premise
especially, there's
a lot of steps involved.
You have to get your hardware
and configure that hardware.
But that's only step one.
Once you have the
hardware, you then
need to get the
open source bits.
Sometimes you might
do this vanilla,
or sometimes you might use
a Hadoop or Spark vendor,
like Cloudera or Hortonworks.
But then you have to install
that software and configure it,
tune it, and only
really after you're
done with that are you actually
ready to start processing data.
Now, if you wanted to use Spark
and Hadoop on day zero or day
one, you're probably not using
Spark and Hadoop on day one
with this process.
It's probably taken
days, weeks, or months
to actually get this
working properly.
There's even more
headaches if you actually
want to set up multiple
clusters, maybe
cluster for production
cluster for development.
So the scaling makes your
life really difficult.
So say you start
off with a cluster
and you want to expand
it because you ran out
of HDFS space, which
is used to store data
and Spark and Hadoop clusters.
Well, there's going to be a lag
of time between when you have
the capacity that you
start with and have
the capacity that you need.
This also may require you to
actually take your resources
offline or have
impaired functionality.
Probably your
business or the need
to actually process
your data is not
stopping for you
while you're actually
scaling this cluster up.
You're actually probably
compounding matters,
and things are
probably piling up
that you wish you could get to.
You also have to really
babysit utilization.
And this is a really
big problem, especially
for accountants.
You're paying for
a lot of capacity,
but you're probably not running
your big data infrastructure
at 100% all the time.
That means that you're probably
paying for overcapacity.
Conversely, you could
pay for undercapacity,
but that's not really a
great solution either,
because then you have less
capacity than you actually
need to answer any
of your questions.
So you have to really be very
careful about how you plan out
your capacity and try and
smooth out your utilization
as much as possible.
Ultimately, you're not
paying for what you use.
This is a really big problem.
And one of the big complaints of
the Spark and Hadoop ecosystem
are they're great
tools, and oddly enough,
a lot of it's free open source.
But it can be very, very
costly to run and maintain.
We don't want you to
have this problem.
Spark and Hadoop
are great tools,
and they bring a
lot to the table.
But you shouldn't worry
about the cost and complexity
of running these tools to
take advantage of them.
So I did mention
Cloudera and Hortonworks.
If anybody in the room is
familiar with Cloudera,
Hortonworks, or MapR and you're
using them, just to throw out,
all three are supported
on Google Cloud Platform.
They all have different
ways to bootstrap clusters,
so there's things like
Cloudera Manager or Ambari
or Cloudbreak.
If you want to use those on
Google Cloud, you totally can.
And you'd get a lot of
benefits from doing that.
You're going to get
low pricing for VMs,
you're going be able
to use cloud storage.
You could possibly use Cloud
Bigtable instead of HBase.
So there's a lot of
benefits for doing.
That so just to say, if
you are tied to these
or really love
these vendors, you
can definitely bring them
and lift and shift them
to Google Cloud Platform.
So we kind of offer
a suite of ways
to run the giant Apache
and Spark ecosystem.
And that's maybe
actually worth a note.
So Apache and Spark are
sort of the two most
well-known components, but
it's a really big ecosystem
of related tools.
And I've never really
found a better way
of referring to it, other than
the Apache Spark and Hadoop
ecosystem.
So there's a lot of tools that
you can run on these clusters.
And we have a whole
host of options
to allow you to run this
software on Cloud platform.
As I mentioned, you could take
your on-premise or other cloud
Hadoop vendor and bring
it to Google Cloud,
like a Cloudera or Hortonworks.
We started off the journey
with Cloud Dataproc
by offering what we call bdutil,
which is a set of command line
scripts.
They're open source
and they're on GitHub,
and they allow you to bootstrap
kind of a lightweight Spark
and Hadoop cluster.
Some of our large customers
actually started using bdutil
and have moved to Dataproc.
But if you want to use
bdutil and get started
with a kind of lightweight
Spark and Hadoop cluster,
you totally can.
But with Cloud Dataproc, we
thought we could do better.
With bdutil you're still
kind of manually setting up
the cluster.
There's still a little
babysitting you have to do.
It can be kind of
difficult to submit jobs.
For instance, you might
have to use a command line
to do a lot of these things.
That might not be a
problem for some users,
but for your average
business user,
you probably don't
want them to have
to use an SSH window or
terminal window to go interact
with Spark and Hadoop clusters.
So Cloud Dataproc,
we really tried
to do a little bit
better and focus
on everything except your data.
So we take care of
the infrastructure,
we take care of the software.
You bring your
data and your jobs,
and you can use Spark and
Hadoop without worrying about
too much else.
So there's a lot of open source
components, as I mentioned.
And they map to different
Google Cloud products
in different ways.
So a lot of these products
you can run on Cloud Dataproc.
So if you're familiar
with the Hadoop ecosystem,
Cloud Dataproc uses YARN.
And a lot of the applications
in that ecosystem
will run on YARN.
So if you're using
them, you can generally
come and use Cloud Dataproc.
We also have other services
that are in their own ways,
tied to some of these
open source products.
And I'll get to how
they're tied in a minute.
But for instance, if
you're using HBase,
you might want to check
out Cloud Bigtable.
If you're interested in Apache
Beam or Crunch or Flume,
Cloud Dataflow is a
really great solution
that you might
want to check out.
And additionally, if you're
tied to things like Impala
or Century or HDFS,
we have products
that map to sort of all
of these technologies.
So Cloud Dataproc handles, I
would say the majority of them.
But around the
edges, we also have
a lot of products that
can fill in the gaps.
So I mentioned that
these products were all
inspired by open source
technologies in different ways.
So a lot of the open
source ecosystem
is based on papers
that Google has
released throughout the years.
So for example, the relationship
between Bigtable and HBase.
In other cases, the
open source ecosystem
has kind of evolved
in and of itself.
At this point, Google's
also very actively involved
in contributing back
to that open source
ecosystem, a great example
being Apache Beam, which
allows you to create batch or
stream pipelines in kind of one
language with one
SDK and one model,
and run them on many
different routers,
rather it's Cloud Dataflow
or Flink or Spark.
So interestingly,
a lot of the things
that run on Cloud Dataproc
were inspired by things
that Google has
done in the past.
And a lot of things that could
run on Dataproc in the future
are inspired by things that
Google is doing in the present
to try and grow this
ecosystem all together.
So let's talk about Cloud
Dataproc just a little bit more
specifically.
So Cloud Dataproc is a way
to create Spark and Hadoop
clusters that are
generally fast, low cost,
and easy to use.
And the way that we do that is
we rely on a lot of the things
that the Google Cloud Platform
brings to the Spark and Hadoop
ecosystem.
And I'll talk about
what things we rely on,
but we've both tried to focus
on making the open source
components run really well
and tuning some of them,
and I can talk
about that, but also
bring a lot of the strengths
of the Google Cloud Platform
to open source.
And the point I make
here is, it's not
about just installing Spark
and Hadoop on some servers
and calling it good.
There's a lot of really
deep integrations,
optimizations, and
thought that goes
into making Spark and Hadoop
fast, easy, and cost-effective.
As an example, say you want
a Spark or Hadoop cluster.
I started off with
that really long line
of having to rack servers
and configure servers.
But even if you
don't focus on that,
you still have to get
the open source software
and tune it and customize
it and debug it.
With Cloud Dataproc, we want
that process to be one click.
We want you to be able to
fill out a very simple form,
and with one click
create your cluster.
Cloud Dataproc is interesting,
and I'll show it in my demo.
We don't abstract away all
of the complexities and knobs
in the open source ecosystem.
And in some ways, Cloud Dataproc
is sort of an anti-Google Cloud
product, because we do
expose that messiness to you
if you want it.
We don't necessarily
try and prevent you
from doing bad things.
We want you to know this is
a full-on Spark and Hadoop
cluster.
If you want to tune
specific properties
or do very specific
customizations,
you totally can.
We try and make it easy for you
and optimize as much as we can
for you, but with a lot of these
tools, they're very knobby.
And sometimes people want to
tune and poke those knobs.
And we totally let you.
So if you want, you can
configure your cluster.
And we have a set of
tools and API endpoints
to try and make that very easy.
So that could take 20 seconds.
And by 90 seconds or so, you
should have your cluster.
So we go from possibly
hours or days or weeks
to less than three
or four minutes.
As I mentioned, what
we're trying to do
is bring the open
source ecosystem
to Google Cloud Platform.
So we have a lot of products.
And we don't want Dataproc
to just be isolated,
because having just Spark
and Hadoop by itself
isn't super useful.
We want you to be able
to use Spark and Hadoop
with other products that
we have in our platform,
and I have some of them
shown on this slide.
For example, we want you to be
able to use Spark and Hadoop
with Google Cloud Storage,
which is part of the demo,
as a replacement for the
Hadoop Distributed File System.
If you want to use
Bigtable, we want
you to be able to use Spark
and Hadoop with Bigtable.
Same thing goes for BigQuery.
If you're using BigQuery as
an enterprise data warehouse,
we want you to be able to use
that powerful enterprise data
warehouse with the really
powerful Spark and Hadoop
ecosystem.
We've tried to
make it very easy,
focusing on moving existing
workloads to Cloud Dataproc.
So generally, Spark and Hadoop
have been out for a while.
And in one way or another,
a lot of customers
have data and workloads
that they want to migrate.
We don't want that
migration to be painful.
Generally that migration
should be pretty easy.
You copy your data, step
one, to Google Cloud Storage.
Step two, you should
be able to change
just a few lines of your job.
Really, the biggest change
you should need to make
is just changing the URI prefix
of where your data is located.
Instead of being on HDFS,
it's in Cloud Storage.
You really shouldn't need
to make any other changes
than that.
So moving your
actual code should
be very, very easy,
almost as easy
as just copying your data over.
And then step three, you
actually use Cloud Dataproc.
So this is an example job.
It's from the Spark examples.
And it's a job that
is reading from HDFS.
In this case, you can see,
and it may be hard to see,
and I apologize.
HDFS is just stricken
and we replace
the URI prefixed with GS
for Google Cloud Storage.
So if I wanted to move this
example job to Dataproc,
that's the only change I need
to make, aside from making sure
that the data I'm reading
exists in Cloud Storage
and has the same file structure.
So again, very,
very easy to move
work, because moving work and
recoating things is not a value
add.
You're not focused on your data,
and we don't really want that.
Under the hood a little bit.
So Cloud Dataproc is, for
all intents and purposes,
a Spark and Hadoop cluster.
And you can create multiple
clusters in a project
and submit work
to those clusters.
Those clusters are built
on existing Cloud Platform
technologies.
So it's built on Compute Engine.
Cloud Dataproc clusters have
one or more master nodes.
You have a set of worker nodes.
And then you can create
preemptible worker nodes
that take advantage
of preemptible VMs.
For anybody that's not
familiar with preemtible VMs,
they're Compute Engine VMs,
they're a special type.
There's a tradeoff.
They have substantially
lower cost,
but they also have a maximum
lifetime of 24 hours.
They're basically built on
spare capacity and Google data
centers.
And if we need
that capacity back,
you lose the preemptible VM.
Well, preemtible
VMs may be great
for compute-intensive workloads
with Spark and Hadoop.
You can use them
with Cloud Dataproc.
So again, we're trying
to not only just rely
on the lower general costs
of Google Cloud platform,
but allow you to use the super
low cost aspects of Google
Cloud Platform to bring your
data processing costs down even
further.
Clusters in Cloud Dataproc do
have HDFS attached to them,
based on persistent disk.
We generally advise
customers don't actually
store any type of persistent
data on this, because A,
you don't want your
persistent data
to be ephemeral with your
ephemeral Spark or Hadoop
cluster.
And then B, you can actually
get better performance often
with Google Cloud
Storage than you can
with HDFS, that's based
on persistent disk.
And then with your clusters,
you can read and write.
Generally most customers
will use Google Cloud Storage
to do that.
Going into a little
bit more detail,
Cloud Dataproc has
an API, a REST API.
And our client tools
talk to that REST API.
That's the same REST API
that anybody can use.
And the engineering
team, which I
have to give enormous credit to,
they're a very passionate group
of people and I would not
be able to actually talk
about Cloud Dataproc if they
weren't dedicated and awesome,
has put a lot of
time and thought
into making the API
expressive, yet easy to use.
That API really has
three endpoints-- one
for managing clusters,
one for managing jobs.
And there's an API
endpoint for operations.
So on all of these
compute nodes,
we have a Cloud
Dataproc agent which
talks to our control plane.
And this is really
how we kind of
create the glue of the
Spark and Hadoop cluster
and allow for some
interesting things,
like being able to
submit and manage
work and interact with
YARN on the cluster.
We build an image,
it's based on Debian.
And the open source
components are
built using another Apache
project called Apache Bigtop.
So basically we build
our own custom sort
of open source distribution of
the Spark and Hadoop ecosystem.
If you haven't used
Dataproc before,
the team takes great
pride in making sure
that we not only version all
of the versions of Dataprocs,
you can actually select
which bundle of components
you want to use and
their version set.
We also generally try
to release frequently.
So for example, our preview
image for Cloud Dataproc
is based on Hadoop 2.8,
which is late and breaking.
Our production image right
now uses very recent versions
of both Hadoop and Spark.
If you want to use
older versions,
you can always go back
and use older versions
of Cloud Dataproc.
The goal here is to allow people
to use the set of versions
that they really want to and
not lag for weeks, months,
or quarters behind,
but also not just
put beta software on clusters
and force people to dog food.
So as I mentioned, all
of our client tools
are built on a REST API.
Generally there's three
client tools, or three ways
that people interact
with clusters.
There is the Google
Cloud Console.
There's the Google Cloud SDK,
which is often seen or known
as G Cloud.
And then there's SSH.
Since this is built
on Compute Engines,
you can interact with
the compute nodes
as if they were just regular
VMs, because they are.
So you can SSH into the
master and worker nodes.
Pricing, a very common
question for Cloud Dataproc.
So with your--
excuse me, I should
be able to pronounce
my own product name.
With your Cloud
Dataproc cluster,
you pay for the compute
and storage charges
that make up your cluster.
And then there's a very low
$0.01 premium per virtual CPU
on top of that, that we charge
for all of the awesome things
that we provide as
part of Cloud Dataproc.
It sounds scary, but we're
actually very cost-effective,
if you compare Cloud
Dataproc to other providers.
The source was actually
moved in the slide,
and I kind of have to
duck here, but it's there.
It's actually based on
an O'Reilly article,
it's a comparison between
Amazon EMR and Cloud Dataproc.
And you can see in
general, Cloud Dataproc
runs jobs faster.
That's important because
we bill by the minute.
We don't round up
to the nearest hour.
So if you use a
cluster for 13 minutes,
you pay for 13
minutes, not one hour.
We've also really been
optimizing Cloud Dataproc
to make processing faster.
And this is a really
important point,
because the goal is not to
just let things stagnate.
We actually want to speed up
your data processing workloads.
It does mean that you might
use less Cloud Dataproc,
and we actually see
that as a victory.
So this is an example
of a feature which
we'll be rolling out soon
to Cloud Dataproc, where
we changed out the SSL mechanism
or provider used in our Cloud
Storage Connector from the
default implementation to one
based on Google's
fork of OpenSSL.
And you can see that
reads have gotten,
or will get in most cases,
substantially faster.
Writes will also see
an improvement as well.
And I mention this
to really showcase,
a goal is to have you use
less Dataproc because you're
able to do more with the
same amount, or with less.
So the supported
components-- a big ecosystem,
there's a lot of
stuff that you can
run on Cloud Dataproc clusters.
By default, we install
the most common packages.
So that's Spark,
Hadoop, Hive, Pig.
Some of those packages are
tricky because something
like Hadoop includes--
I don't know how many
weird [INAUDIBLE]
subprojects and
tangents of projects.
But generally those are
the four core components.
We build a lot of the
ecosystem, however, in Bigtop.
We have a repository
with each release.
So if you wanted to install
something like Zeppelin,
that's built in Bigtop.
It's actually in Bigtop.
So if you went onto a cluster or
used an initialization action,
which I will show
you in my demo,
you could install Zeppelin,
because we actually
have pre-built it.
The reason I call this out,
it's a very common question
of how much can we
install on a cluster?
Well, you can install
really, whatever you want.
We try to keep it
lean because we
don't want to burden clusters
and install stuff that people
aren't going to use, and is
just going to take up resources
and make their data processing
slower and make them sad,
and then that makes us sad.
So I'm going to go to
a Cloud Dataproc demo
to tie together
some of the things
that I've mentioned thus far.
In this demo, we're
going to do a few things.
We are going to
create a cluster.
And I'm going to create
a fairly sizable cluster.
It's not the biggest
cluster in the world,
but I think it's modestly big.
We're going to query
a large set of data.
And I'll talk about the
data and the queries
that we're going to run.
We're going to see the
output of those queries,
and that actually hints at some
of the really fancy tooling
around Cloud Dataproc.
And then we're going to delete
the cluster, just to show you
that you only need the
cluster that's really designed
as an ephemeral solution.
You only need the cluster
as long as you actually
have data to process.
So the data that we
are going to query
is based on the New
York taxi dataset.
So from 2009 to 2015, the New
York City Limousine and Taxi
Commission released all
taxi trips and Uber trips
in New York.
Uncompressed, the dataset
is about 270 gigabytes.
It's in CSV format, and
there's about 1.2 billion trips
in this dataset.
So I'm going to switch here.
So this is the
Google Cloud console,
if you have not seen it before.
And this is the form or the
page to create a Cloud Dataproc
cluster.
I could create this cluster
through just a raw API call.
I could also use G Cloud.
I'm showing you through
the Cloud console,
just because it is generally
much easier to demo
than trying to
type in a console.
First thing that we're going to
do is give the cluster a name.
I'm going to call my
cluster james demo.
The second thing that you
generally will want to fill in
is the zone where you're
going to create a cluster.
Cloud Dataproc is
generally available
wherever Compute
Engine is available.
That is going to be true
as Compute Engine is
made available in more regions
as Google Cloud expands.
The Cloud Dataproc team wants
to be available everywhere
that Google Cloud is available.
So right now, the list
is here and the list
will grow over time.
I'm going to choose
US Central, just
because I suspect
that's going to give us
pretty good performance since
we're in the US right now.
You then choose how you want
to configure your master
and worker nodes.
And these are very analogous
to traditional Hadoop master
and worker nodes.
From master nodes, we offer
three different varieties.
And one of them is
actually a new feature,
which is having a cluster
that's just one node.
That means your master
is your worker--
good for development,
exploration, possibly
education, lightweight
data science.
The default option is
just having one master.
We also offer the ability to
have high availability, which
is three masters.
And that provides,
it's based on ZooKeeper
and it provides YARN and
HDFS high availability.
I'm just going to create
a standard cluster here
because we don't need
high availability.
You can choose the
machine type that you
want to use in your cluster.
In the web UI here, we have all
of the standard non-shared CPU
machine types.
You can also use custom
VMs with Cloud Dataproc.
So if you actually wanted
to use a machine type that
was based on six CPUs and
58.62 gigabytes of RAM,
you could absolutely do that
through the API and the command
line.
In this case, I'm
just going to choose
an n1-standard-16
for my master node.
And worker nodes, same thing.
Something that is
worth calling out here
is in the very near
future, Cloud Dataproc
will be supporting
64 core VMs, which
were recently announced on
beta on Google Cloud Platform.
And I called that
out because often,
a lot of the improvements that
are made to the underlying
services of a cloud
platform, whether it's
Compute Engine or Cloud Storage
or our networking, Cloud
Dataproc benefits from those.
So as a lot of other components,
can Google Cloud get better,
it means that using
Spark and Hadoop
gets incrementally
better as well.
For my worker nodes, I'm
going to use an 8 core
and n1-standard-8,
just in our testing.
These work usually pretty well.
I'm going to go ahead and
create kind of a modestly
large cluster here.
Let's go ahead
and add 200 nodes.
That will give us 1600 YARN
cores, and about 4.7 terabytes
of YARN RAM.
We're not going to
use a lot of HDFS,
so I'm actually going to lower
the amount of persistent disks
that we attach because
we're not really
going to be writing to HDFS.
And then you can see there's
some advanced options that
are optional, that
you can configure.
I could do things
like use networking,
and Cloud Dataproc
supports a wide variety
of networking options.
You can select, as I
mentioned, different versions
of Cloud Dataproc.
In this case, the configuration
I'm going to apply
is the one [INAUDIBLE] I'm
going to install Presto
in my cluster, just
to show you that you
can install a wide variety
of things on Cloud Dataproc.
And Presto is actually not part
of the sort of Apache big data
ecosystem, but I'm going
to install it and show you
that it works.
And we're going to
run all of our queries
through Presto, actually.
So we'll go ahead and
create that cluster.
All right.
So the cluster is in the
process of bootstrapping itself.
Let's go ahead and fill out
the form to submit our job.
Now, with Cloud Dataproc,
one of the things
that we've paid a
lot of attention to
is trying to make it really easy
to interact with your cluster.
And often when you
want to submit work--
in this case, we call
them jobs-- to clusters,
you have to use of
complicated tooling
or you have to log in
and open an SSH window.
And that's just no good.
If you have a lot
of work to do, we
want it to be very
easy for you to submit
your Spark, or PySpark, or Spark
SQL scripts to Cloud Dataproc.
The other thing that
I'll show you here
is the Jobs API and
the tools on top of it
allow us to not
only submit work,
but we can actually
see the streamed output
from those jobs.
And the nice thing is, I
could actually submit the job
and close my computer
and throw it in a fire,
and that job is
still going to run.
So it's not tied to the
persistence of that one
computer, which is actually
a really annoying problem
if you use Spark
and Hadoop a lot,
that you open up
a terminal window
and if that terminal window
goes away, unless you thought
about it, that job is
going to just vanish
when you leave your computer.
So first thing, I'm going
to choose the cluster
that I want to run the job on.
The next thing I'm going to
do is choose the job type.
Right now we support
six job types.
I'm going to run Pig,
and people always
give me a hard time about this,
but there's a very good reason.
The reason I'm going
to use Pig is because I
am going to abuse Pig.
I'm actually just
going to use Pig
to shell out to call Presto.
A little convoluted, but
it's convoluted on purpose
to show you that
we're not putting up
bumpers or guardrails.
You can do really,
whatever you want.
The goal here is to allow you
to have life be very easy.
So for example, if I wanted
to just run Spark SQL,
I could enter a file
with my Spark SQL
on Cloud Storage, or just the
raw query text, very easy.
And me using Pig to
shell out to Presto,
that's a bit more
complicated and interesting.
But that's really to
show you that if you
want to develop with
Spark and Hadoop,
we're not going to try
and artificially limit
you and constrain you too much.
So with my Pig script
here, I am going
to specify my query file, which
is inside of a Cloud Storage
bucket.
And this SQL script is going
to essentially just query
Presto with a few queries.
Let's go take a look at the
cluster that we created.
I was talking a little
bit, unfortunately,
and just blabbering a lot.
My cluster actually was ready
probably two minutes ago.
So our 200 node cluster with
1600 cores is ready to go.
All of the VMs are up, and
it's ready to take work.
If I wanted to, I
can edit this cluster
and do things like add
and remove worker nodes.
I can add and remove
preemptible nodes.
And that's while the
cluster is running.
So if I wanted to add
more notes to this cluster
while it was running,
I totally can.
And just because
it sounds like fun,
let's go ahead and do that.
So let's submit our job.
And the job is now
running on my cluster.
And as the job gets
started, you'll
actually see the job
output start spooling here
live to the screen.
So you can actually see
that first thing that's
going to happen if you
have really good eyesight
is we're going to
create a external table
and then start running queries
against that external table.
This is an example of us trying
to make life easy for you.
So the job was sent
to the cluster.
We're interacting with
open source components
and feeding the
output back to you.
Job's running, let's go
ahead and say oh, I'm
worried about this
job, let's go ahead
and add 20 more nodes
or 10 more nodes,
just because we want
a really big cluster.
So we're going to go ahead
and update the cluster
while the job is running.
It's not going to
impact the job at all.
And you can see that the job
is starting to spool output
to this screen live.
It's going to update.
You'd have the same experience
if you used the G Cloud
command.
So if you said G Cloud,
Dataproc job submit Pig,
and then fed it the
required arguments,
you're going to see this
output to the screen as well.
This job is not writing
anything anywhere.
It's really just emitting
the results in standard out.
Obviously could
save results back
to BigQuery or Cloud Storage
or a number of other cloud
products.
You can see that while
the cluster is resizing,
it doesn't go down.
There is no
interruption of service.
It just continues to
work without hassle,
without you needing to do
anything much more specific
than that.
We just went and queried
all of that data.
It took a minute and 33 seconds.
What's really impressive
about that is this data
is in Cloud Storage.
So between Cloud Storage, where
this giant dataset is stored
and the Spark and
Hadoop cluster,
it was able to read
the data and query it
in one minute and 33 seconds.
And that's really because
there's really fast networking
in our data centers in general.
And Cloud Dataproc
cluster is able to use
that really fast
networking to go query
Cloud Storage in a jiffy.
So actually we're just
done with this cluster.
That's really what
I wanted to show.
So let's go ahead
and say, we're done.
We actually don't need
this cluster anymore.
We'll just go ahead and
delete that cluster.
And the cluster is
going to go away.
No fuss, no hassle.
So what happened?
We created a cluster
that was 1600 YARN cores.
It ran the Spark and
Hadoop ecosystem.
In this case, we took
advantage of Presto
and we did it in one click.
To put a little bit more
detail in what we did,
we created an
external table that
was based on the data in
the Cloud Storage bucket.
And then we just ran
a few simple queries
against that data.
These aren't the most
complicated queries
in the world, but it is
reading a substantial portion
of the data from Cloud
Storage using Presto.
Ultimately, and I've
run this demo enough
and run the costs on all
these different clouds.
We didn't have this cluster
for longer than 10 minutes.
So we're going to actually be
charged the 10 minute minimum
for Cloud Dataproc.
Everything beyond 10
minutes is per minute.
That 210 node cluster
costs $12.85 to run.
If you ran it in Amazon
EMR or HDInsight,
you'd be paying substantially
more respectively, just
based on either our rounding
or just more expensive costs
on a per minute basis overall.
So I've told you
Dataproc is awesome.
We have some just kind of
random quotes from Twitter.
If you don't believe me,
you can search Twitter,
these are definitely there.
We've had both customers
offload from other clouds
to Dataproc or from on
premise to Dataproc.
And we've really tried to
focus on customer feedback
to make Dataproc better.
That's a core part of how we
improve the platform overall.
Ultimately, we also try to share
best practices with customers
to make using Dataproc easier.
And I want to share some
of those tips with you.
So if you are interested in
using Spark and Hadoop on Cloud
Platform.
Or you are using Cloud
Dataproc already,
you have a better experience.
The first tip that we
recommend to a lot of customers
is to split clusters and jobs.
Canonically on premise, you most
often will have one cluster,
and everybody will just
submit all of their jobs
to that cluster.
And they may try and
do it intelligently
and submit their jobs over
time or schedule them,
or they may just submit all of
the jobs and see what happens.
With Cloud Dataproc, you
can have multiple clusters.
And the clusters
can be right sized
and shaped and
conditioned and configured
to run specific types of jobs.
So if I have a bunch of jobs
and my first two jobs run pretty
quickly, and I know I
can run them in parallel,
I can send them
off to Cluster A.
If I have two slower jobs
that are very intensive
and I want them
to run separately,
you can run them on
separate clusters.
We also support the use of cloud
labels with Cloud Dataproc.
Labels are a key value
pair that you can
associate with cloud resources.
With Cloud Dataproc
that's really important,
because if I have these
three different clusters
and I wanted to tag
maybe organization
equals A, B, and C, I can then
do cost accounting and billing
accounting based on
those labels and actually
filter and list by
those labels separately.
So if you are running Spark
and Hadoop in an enterprise
setting, and you actually
wanted to do something
like be able to figure out
how much people were using
or trace that back,
labels make it very easy.
And splitting clusters and
jobs makes it very easy.
And labels can apply to
both Cloud Dataproc clusters
and jobs.
Development and production.
If you need to have a production
and development environment,
and you want to have maybe a
staging environment, since you
can have multiple
clusters, it's very easy
to have separate prod,
dev, tests, whatever,
experimentation clusters.
You just create a new cluster.
The nice thing here is
if, for example, you
wanted to do some
development and you
didn't want to break or impact
other users or other jobs,
just create a
development cluster.
Additionally, since you can
read data, for instance,
from Cloud Storage for
multiple different clusters,
if I wanted to have all of
my production work occurring
and then do some development,
maybe I have a bunch of Spark
and I want to test
it in Spark 2.2.
You can create a new
cluster, use a preview image,
and start testing against
that Cloud Storage bucket.
You don't have to do
anything differently,
you don't have to copy
data, it's very easy to do.
And we've had a lot
of success trying
to help customers
migrate to the idea
that you can create
clusters when you need them.
If you don't need them,
you can delete them.
There's really no
reason, honestly, to--
I would advocate if you're not
using a cluster, delete it.
We don't want you
to keep it around.
That's not good for
you, and ultimately that
just makes it not good for us.
So create and delete
clusters often.
If you have a bunch
of work and you
want to schedule creating and
deleting clusters, you can.
As an example, if you are using
something like Apache Airflow,
you can actually create
Cloud Dataproc clusters,
run your jobs using
Apache Airflow,
and then delete your cluster.
Great example of
an ephemeral use
case where you can create
and delete clusters often
just based on whenever
you actually need them.
Cloud Storage.
A lot of people that shift from
on-premise to Cloud Dataproc
ask us, what's the
performance of Cloud Storage?
How does it compare with HDFS?
Why should I use Cloud Storage?
Generally speaking,
Cloud Storage
is going to give you a
very high throughput.
It has its own sets
of features which
you may find really
useful, like being
able to apply security
controls or having auditing
on Cloud Storage buckets.
It also allows you to use
data and Cloud Storage
between many different
Google Cloud products.
You could do federated
queries with BigQuery
on that Cloud Storage bucket.
So moving away from
HDFS not only brings
performance and cost benefits
for your Spark and Hadoop use
cases, but it may provide
a lot of other benefits
for data that would
normally have just
been living in HDFS, because
that's where it would live.
The job submission API.
If you are submitting
work to your clusters,
you can submit work really
in many different ways.
There's probably an
infinite number of ways
when you look at
it to submit work.
You could SSH in and
use spark-submit.
You could use
something like Airflow.
You could write a Python script
that's sitting on a crontab,
just submitting work whenever
you have it scheduled.
Generally we advocate that you
use our job submission API,
and there's a lot
of reasons for that.
It allows you to do
things like apply labels
to jobs, as you saw.
You can see the
output from jobs.
It makes it much
easier, so you only
have to fill in a few arguments
to actually submit work
to a cluster.
So with the job
API, we've really
tried to make it easy
for you to broker work
and interact with work and
manage work with clusters.
So as I've sort of shown
you and talked about,
you can scale
clusters at any time.
We scaled the
cluster in the demo.
As I mentioned,
I didn't demo it,
but you can use custom VM types
for your master and worker
nodes.
And you can use preemptible
nodes with your clusters
if you want to use
preemptible nodes.
One thing that I ran
to install Presto
is what I called
initialization action.
Initialization
actions are scripts
which can be interpreted
on the cluster,
so these could be shell scripts,
they could be Python scripts,
they could be Ruby scripts.
These scripts are run after the
services start on the cluster.
They're really useful
for doing things
like staging jars or
copying data locally
that you might want to
test on or in this case
as we saw, installing Presto.
We also have a mechanism
through our client tooling
to allow you to set
properties in cluster files.
So if you wanted to modify, say,
properties in the core site XML
file, we have a way for
you to easily do that.
So you don't have to go
in and SSH in or write
an initialization
action to do it.
So we've tried to create two
really powerful but easy ways
for you to customize clusters
when you start them up.
There is a bunch of new
Cloud Dataproc features
that I want to talk
about that we've
released in the last few weeks
in anticipation for next.
We've actually
gotten a few more out
that I can talk about as well.
The first is restartable jobs.
So in our API and
our client tooling,
traditionally when a job ran
and failed, that was sort of it.
The job would just
sit and have failed.
In some cases, this
may not be desirable.
You actually may want
a job to restart.
For example, you
may have a streaming
job that just runs
out of memory,
and it was kind
of a corner case.
And you want that
job to restart.
With our client tooling now,
when you submit a job to Cloud
Dataproc, you can
actually specify
the number of times
per hour that you
want that job to restart.
This is really useful
for long-running jobs.
We designed it with kind of an
eye on streaming applications,
as we looked to better
support and provide
support for streaming
applications on Dataproc.
So that way you can be confident
that if your work fails,
we're going to kick
off that job for you.
GPUs were recently
announced on Cloud Platform
and made available
to Compute Engine.
This is a good example
of when innovations
occur on other parts
of the Cloud Platform.
If they make sense to bring to
the Spark and Hadoop ecosystem,
we absolutely want to.
So when you create Cloud
Dataproc clusters now,
you can specify the
number of accelerators,
which are essentially
GPUs, that you want attach
to either your master
or worker nodes
in your cluster from zero,
which is the default, up to 8.
If anybody is really
interested in GPUs and Spark,
I think you would probably know
this is an evolving ecosystem,
and I think the Spark support
and kind of other ecosystem
support for GPUs is
an evolving story.
But there's a lot
of cases we actually
may want to use GPUs
now or in the future,
and it was very
important to us to allow
you to use them with Cloud
Dataproc as soon as possible.
I'd briefly mentioned
single node clusters.
A common request that
we had from customers
was they wanted to just
run very small tests,
and they actually didn't
need a full blown cluster.
So they just wanted to run a
really quick test using Spark.
They wanted to do really
lightweight data science.
With single node
clusters, you create
a cluster which
is just one node,
it's the master and worker node.
That way you don't have to
create a full blown Spark
and Hadoop cluster,
because for something
like, if you're leading
a class, for example,
on how to use Spark, you don't
need giant clusters to do that.
You actually just need
probably a smallish VM
that has Spark installed.
And with single
node clusters, we've
really tried to
make it easy for you
to create these lightweight
clusters for experimentation
and development.
Regional endpoints and
private IP addresses.
So with Cloud Dataproc, when
we launched almost a year ago
our API and the client
tools that used our API,
used one region,
which was global.
Recently we've added individual
regions for each Compute Engine
region and Cloud Dataproc.
So in our API and
via our client tools,
you can now isolate
to a specific region.
So you could say, if
you're using our tools,
say use the US region.
That means the calls are
going to that region.
We've distributed
our control plane,
and essentially we've
stood up individual stacks
of the control infrastructure
for Cloud Dataproc and all
of these individual regions.
The benefit there is you
may get better performance.
So for example, if
you are in Europe
and you wanted to use
the Europe region,
you may get much
better performance
by isolating to that region
for applications that
are working entirely in Europe.
Clusters and cloud
resources have--
going to private IPs.
Clusters and
resources have often
had public IPs attached to them.
One very, very common request
from large enterprise customers
especially was, I
want clusters but I
don't want them to have a
public IP attached, because that
makes my security
people very sadface.
So with the recent launch
of Cloudpath last week,
we now support creating
clusters that do not have
a public IP attached to them.
And an important
differentiator here
is we try to make it very easy.
So this isn't something
that's unique to Dataproc.
But the way that we've tried
to innovate and make life
better for all Google
Cloud customers here
is to make it very easy to
create clusters that don't have
a public IP attached to them.
Both of these
features are in beta,
and they were both commonly
requested features.
And that drives back
to, we try to respond
to customer feedback.
So honestly, if you are
interested in using Dataproc,
or you are and you have
ideas, requests, gripes,
loves, complaints,
send them our way.
We try to be very, very
customer-focused and hands on.
How to get started
with Cloud Dataproc.
There's a few different
sessions which
either directly or indirectly
mention Cloud Dataproc.
Some of these sessions have
unfortunately already passed.
But the good news is, I believe
the videos will be on YouTube.
So if you are interested,
this is really
kind of the introduction
to a lot of these concepts.
A lot of these other tools
go into very specific ideas
and concepts.
If you want to get hands-on
literally right now,
there is a ton of
Codelabs downstairs.
You can get started with
Cloud Dataproc Codelabs.
We also have a set of
quickstarts and tutorials
to show you how to create
clusters and submit jobs.
And just to sort of go back
to the initialization actions,
a lot of what we do
that's customer-facing,
that's open source, we have in
various GitHub repositories.
So we have our
initialization actions,
for example, for installing
Zeppelin and Presto there.
If you need help, there's
many different ways
you can get help
with Cloud Dataproc.
We have documentation online.
We also have our Release Notes.
I again have to give the
engineering team credit here.
We release updates
to Cloud Dataproc
fairly frequently, which
we really take pride in
because we're trying
to bring the latest
and greatest of
this large ecosystem
with a ton of innovations
to make it better.
So if you have been or are
interested in Dataproc,
watch our Release
Notes pretty closely,
because they usually will
change about every week
for the better.
If you actually
want hands-on help,
a really good place is Stack
Overflow, using the Google
Cloud Dataproc tag.
You could probably
indirectly meet many members
of the Cloud Dataproc
team based on just answers
from Stack Overflow.
And then we have our
informal email list.
And if you are a Google
Cloud support customer,
that's also an option as well.
And with that, if
there's any questions,
I'm happy to take them.
Other than that, thank
you guys very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]